ورقة مصالحة يا له من انجاز
تاريخي. اعتبر الرئيس اللبناني
كيم يحتفل بطريقته الخاصة. هناك
في بلاد كيم. كل شيء مختلف وكل
ميشيل عون ان انجاز اتفاق ترسيم
الحدود البحرية سينتشل لبنان من
استبدله كيم بعيد اخر. احتفل
سكان بيونج يانج من مدنيين
فهل يتم تجميد مبيعات الاسلحة
الامريكية للمملكة كما قالت
السعودية رفضت الاستجابة
لمناشدات مسؤولين امريكيين تأجيل
قدراتها التكتيكية والنووية
والزعيم الكوري يشرف على التجربة
سابقا? ليأتي ولي العهد السعودي
ويتحدث عن امله في ان تنتج
لكن دون جدوى لتقرر واشنطن
مستقبل العلاقات مع السعودية.
بعيد للام غير الذي اقره كيم فلا
يلومن الا نفسه نعم فعاقبته
الامريكيين يقفون على رؤوس
اصابعهم. وها هما روسيا
اكتفاء ذاتيا في هذا المجال تحد
واضح لواشنطن. فبماذا سيردون?
الله الترسيم الجديد للحدود مع
اسرائيل? وماذا عن شعاراتك
كوريا الشمالي نتحدث. في سياق
اخر كوريا الشمالية تعلن اطلاق
ان بوتين يتراجع يعود بقوة. فهل
هو تكتيك من الرئيس الروسي ام
اعادة النازحين السوريين الى
بلدهم على دفعات بينما حسن نصر
قرار خفض انتاج النفط ضمن مجموعة
اوبك بلس بحسب صحيفة جورنال.
سلسلة اختبارات صاروخية ترمي من
خلالها بيونج يانج لاستعراض
والتطورات الفصائل الفلسطينية
المجتمعة في الجزائر تتوصل الى
الزهور امام تمثال كيم جونج اون
فوق قبر جدته واي شخص سيحتفل
وعسكريين بالذكرى السابعة
والسبعين لتأسيس حزب العمال
قرار اوبك بلس **** سيناتور
امريكي المملكة العرب السعودية
صاروخي كروز استراتيجيين بعيدي
المدى في تجربة هي الاحدث ضمن
مجلس النواب الامريكي نانسي
بيلوسي بالصواريخ النارية.
بالحجارة كما فعلوها ضربة سعودية
لامريكا. القرارات السعودية جعلت
واحتفل بتأمين الغذاء لشعبه
بمزرعة صواريخ. نعم عن مجنون
المملكة خمسين في المئة من
حاجاتها العسكرية وان تحقق
معروفة. احتفالات المجنون عجيبة
وغريبة. كيم احتفل بنائبة رئيسة
امر يمضي وفق طريقة المجنون
الخاص. حتى عيد الام العالمي
والسعودية تلعبان من تحت الطاولة
لتاخذ السعودية ورقة من كتاب
واضافت الصحيفة هددوا ان هذه
الخطوة ستضعف دعم واشنطن للمملكة
وكلماتك التي ازعجتنا بها يا
هذا? الاحتجاجات الايرانية
لم تكتف بعدم الاهتمام لامرنا بل
انها وجهت لنا ضربة عميقة.
تتواصل واضراب عمال النفط ينذر
بازمة اقتصادية. في كل مرة نقول
موسكو وتلقي بها على الولايات
المتحدة ويا لها من ضربة. وبعد
الهاوية التي اسقط فيها كاشفا
انه سيتبعها الاسبوع المقبل بدء
من مكان الاطلاق. واعرب عن رضاه
التام بهذه العملية. الاحداث
مطرقة اصحاب العيون الضيقة? ام
انهم سيتصدون للمسيرات الصينية
الكوري بحدث يحظى باهتمام واسع
ويوصف بعيد الامة واضعين باقات
هنا ستبدأ الدفاعات التايوانية
باجراءات الدفاع عن الجزيرة
والبدء للدفاع عن الجزيرة. فهل
سيستطيع مسمار تايبي الوقوف امام
وتشغيل منظومات الدفاع على طول
الساحل اضافة الى الانتشار
البلاد هو اعلان حرب هي الضربة
الاولى كما تقول التقارير. ومن
خطا احمر في مواجهة تهديدات
الصين فماذا عن مطرقة الصين? هنا
مسامير تلك الدول لكن ماذا عن
المسمار التيواني? تايوان تضع
وزير الدفاع التيواني يتحدث
اختراق اي مسيرات صينية لعمق
والصومال والسودان واليمن وايران
وفق تعبيره لم تفلح واشنطن في دق
لجيان. حيث اوضح لجيان ان
المسامير هي الدول التي كانت
قرار اوبك بلس واضيف عليه قطع
النفط الروسي هنا طويل من
الاشياء حولك مسامير. هكذا قالها
متحدث الخارجية الصينية جو
فرنسا تختنق حرفيا فهل سترأف
الجزائر بحالها? المطرقة الصينية
واشنطن تخطط للسيطرة عليها? نعم.
ان العراق وسوريا ولبنان وليبيا
تدق نعش تيوان. عندما لا تمتلك
سوى المطرقة فانك سترى جميع
الرحمة من عمال مصافي النفط
الفرنسي. الحكومة الفرنسية تصرح
ياتي برسالة عسكرية لبوتين حيث
سينفذ مناورات للحلف وتدريبات
السيارات يمتد لمسافة ثلاثة كيلو
مترات لم ننتهي. لتأتي رصاصة
يقول اعتقد ان بوتين شخص عقلاني
لكنه اخطأ بشكل كبير في
الحرب سيشكل خطرا على الناتو.
فعن اي خطر يتحدثون. وبعد
انهم يدفعون سيارتهم نعم شاهدوا
هذا الفيديو.
جزولي. هذا ليس في سريلانكا يا
سادة هي ازمة نفط ومجاعة طاقة.
فرنسية وهذه سيارتهم. لقد نفذ
الوقود منها يا لا بؤس حالهم.
ان اضراب عمال مصافي النفط اصبح
لا يحتمل. وهؤلاء رجال شرطة
الحسابات. ومن الحسابات
الامريكية الى الازمة الفرنسية.
ويقول اوكرانيا ليس بصدد التخطيط
لعمل عسكري ضد بيلاروسيا. ومن
ليست طرفا في الحرب وذلك حسب
تعبيرها. وبالنسبة للنايتو ها هو
عليها من ايران لكن الخارجية
الايرانية نفت ذلك وقالت انها
التهديد الذي اطلقه رئيس
بلاروسيا ها هو زيلنسكي يتراجع
التراجع الاوكراني الى الاوضاع
الامريكية. هنا الرئيس بايدن
روتينية وقد خطط لها خلال ايام
هنا الامين العام لحلف الناتو
المقاتلة والمروحيات وصواريخ
كروز والمدفعية الصاروخية
كييف نظام ارستي من اصل اربعة
انظمة عليها لصد الطائرات
ينس تولتومبرج يتحدث. يجب ان
تنتصر اوكرانيا. انتصار روسيا في
وطائرات كاميكازي التي تقول
تقارير اعلامية ان روسيا حصلت
الاوكرانية بعد. فما هو الجديد
يا احفاد ستالدين غير بعيد عن
بها زلينسكي. لكن الرئيس
الاوكراني طلب بدعم بلاده
متعهدة بمحاسبة بوتين عن
الصاروخية الاخيرة وبفرض المزيد
من التكاليف الاقتصادية على
موسكو. وهي العقوبات التي طلب
لترد موسكو انها لم تستخدم
اسلحتها الحديثة في الحرب
ذلك اجتمعت الدول السبع واكدت
التزامها بدعم وحدة اوكرانيا
دقائق. فهل يقول الحقيقة ام انها
مجرد خيالات تجري في عقل كاتب
بمنظومات ليشكل درعا يحميه من
الصواريخ والطائرات الروسية. فهل
مؤلف كتاب تفجير اوكرانيا والذي
هرب الى الولايات المتحدة والسبب
اليأس توغل داخل قوات روسيا
واسلحتهم في اوكرانيا بدأت تنفد
تسريب معلومات استخباراتية يقول
نحن نعيش الان الايام الاولى
يستطيع الغرب اجابة طلب زلينسكي?
الرد ياتي من المانيا التي سلمت
نعم. انها تستهدف محطات الطاقة
لكي يكون الظلام احد ليأتي هنا
للحرب العالمية الثالثة وبوتين
يستطيع تدمير اوكرانيا خلال
الدامس. بثلاثة صواريخ فقط جعلت
موسكو ثلث سكان كييف بلا كهرباء.
هوليودي? الاستخبارات لا توافق
الكاتبة نفس الرأي وتوضح ان
الارض. تكتيك روسي جديد في
اوكرانيا يزعج الناتو الظلام
مغرية. هل يقبل بها الاوروبيون
مهلا مهلا. نعم. لقد علمنا الان
تتحول الى اكبر مركز لتوزيع
الغاز في اوروبا. يا لها من عروض
والشتاء والكرة الان في ملعبكم.
بفضل الغاز الروسي تركيا يمكن ان
بقوله. روسيا مستعدة لتزويد
اوروبا بالغاز في فترتي الخريف
سبب تقربك وتملقك لبوتين يا
لخبثك يا حفيد ارطغرل. على
بوتين وكيف سترد اوروبا يا ترى?
بوتين ياتي للاوروبيين بالحل
في منتصف الطريق لانها حصلت على
عرض افضل. ما هذا الذي يقوله
انه غير موثوق به. مضيفا ان
حاملة غاز امريكية حولت وجهتها
يخرج الرئيس الروسي ويصرح ان سعر
الغاز الامريكي اغلى بكثير كما
جسر كيرش ليس كما قبله. روسيا
تعلن عن تكثيف ضرباتها لمواقع
لقد حدثناكم هذه ليست الا
البداية. نعم. فما بعد استهداف
يتغير وتبقى القوة الحقيقية
لاصحابها وموسكو تقولها للغرب.
عسكرية داخل اوكرانيا باسلحة
دقيقة لليوم الثاني على التوالي
عقدة الفلسطينيين. تكتيك موسكو
الجديد. الوضع يتبدل والحال
السعودية وامريكا بدأت الحرب
الباردة يا سادة. ولهذا السبب
في مهمتها. بينما تعلن نظيرتها
في لبنان انجاز المهمة نصر الله
يبارك فان باتت كلماتك الرنانة
ضد اسرائيل يا هذا والجزائر تفك
كوريا الشمالية تمنع الاحتفال
بعيد الام. السلطة العراقية تفشل
للصين. لكن اصحاب العيون الضيقة
لا يرون الخطوط الحمراء. وبين
ولا تبحث عن المجرمين. ها يا
للعجب! وتايوان تضع خطا احمر
ملعب اوروبا. فما الذي يقصده?
وفي فرنسا الشرطة تبحث الوقود
وصائد الطائرات الالماني يصل
كييف. وبوتين يقول الكرة الان في
بوتين يغري اوروبا ويلقي اول
عظمة في طريقها. فمن سيترك صف
امريكا وينضم لصف بوتين يا ترى
موسكو تعلن عن تكتيك جديد في
اوكرانيا والنيتو يرد. وبعد
تهديد بيلاروسيا سيلينسكي يجيب
انها ظروف الحرب التي تجبره على
ذلك?